le meilleur moment en dissipant en fait
j'étais devant ma télé et c'est culte
est l'invité cette banane sont avec
daniel mallet et si elle décide comme ça
une partie en direct sur d8
c'est la première fois toujours que
c'est vrai qu'on va faire à cache-cache
géant non j'ai compté le service le
premier que je trouvais sur le fond d'or
j'étais mort de rire hélas le plateau
tout ce plan sur le plateau et jerry le
sma la colle et qui revient que c'est
notre
[Musique]
le régime est comme des dingues quel
moment il ya des tidianes ça marchait
tellement il a pris ce cache cache très
à coeur car adams ça va du rhin dans les
gorges vous dira oui excusez moi il est
en cavale un million kavanagh non la
trouver
ravi moment ryan a tellement et moi le
mien évidemment c'est le jour où
monsieur m'attendre et quel ordre
mais quel rôle m'a fait une coupe au bol
j'ai fait l'con beau gosse je viens à
l'instant de me prendre un râteau
n'était pas possible à la teinture elle
est restée un an pendant un an j'avais
des rouges et des tata jeanine pendant
seulement c'est un cauchemar
l'invité qui m'a marqué c'est sacha
baron cohen qui le somment unité qui a
réussi à piéger
six lieux il est arrivé et normalement
les tableaux d'améliorer un quart
d'heure c'était vraiment contractuel il
restait pas une ligne et la randonnée
sacha baron cohen lui dit qu'il a appris
à se libérer de menou paire de menottes
et il se met notre assiette
et là il quand s'en vouloir avec un
trombone du beurre ou lors des heurts la
meinau et ça fait pas tardé rapport va
rester on peut tenir
du côté des arrivées on va trouver
regardez peut-être l'écueil sont tombés
là bas noté vos gammes pendant une heure
d'émission est vraiment ciblé et se
disant et l'autre énorme et sacha baron
cohen les mecs énervé j'aurais quand
même
finalement il ya un oiseau avec une
pince monseigneur mais devant ça comme
toulalan la paire de menottes défaut
souverain savoir si tu veux donc se
casse s'il reste aux émissions
j'abandonne car les ai sentis il dépose
la clé les dames en gros il a piraté le
m crac et les missions et avec une force